he's tom e curran the patriots insider
for nbc sports boston you want to jump
in on this there tom
yeah uh first of all yeah they're paying
attention they want to do
better than what tom brady does
regardless they might love them
individually but i've been told by folks
inside that building we're going to be
watching every week and
gosh darn it we do not want to end up
with fewer wins
than the tampa bay buccaneers so that's
a check mark and plus i think the
belichick would be
left in a twitching pool of liquid on
the floor if he ever had a two-win
season
i mean he said that once dan
when the andrew luck previous to him
and the colts bottomed out after peyton
manning curtis painter was their
quarterback
a couple years later belichick said you
know you never want to be late
on the quarterback position i mean
we don't want to be the colts so no it's
i still even wonder even if they went to
a 14 if he'd spend on a quarterback at
the top of the draft
because i think that the idea of getting
committed to that position
at 25 30 million dollars a year even
down the road
he doesn't love it all right i'm i
i stand or sit corrected because i i
would have thought that belichick cares
about the patriots and you know
their seasoning not concerned about what
tom brady is doing
and i don't know if that's a referendum
on belichick do you think belichick
thinks whatever tom does in tampa does
is a referendum on him
no not necessarily but i do think it's
almost like
it's going to turn into a bird magic
thing where they're eyeing each other
and checking on each other and paying
attention to what each other's box
scores are i don't think it's a
coincidence at all dan
that yesterday after the spate of
opt-outs
rob gronkowski tweets out basically
lfg and then brady goes indeed robert
i mean it's just not a coincidence
how many players so far what are we up
to and the opt-out patriots
six six of them okay three three real
real key guys
and then you got the mccourty brothers
yes
have they are they gonna make a decision
soon
it felt like that there might be a
question mark for the
32 year old defensive backs yeah it's
august third
is what seems to be the tentative opt
out date july 28th was the reporting
date and they were going to give it a
week so it's about august 3rd
that hasn't been locked and cemented in
stone i think with devin and jason both
they're they're continuing to
to mullet i mean devin has lost his
secondary mate
in patrick chung but the interesting
thing about belichick is he takes a guy
and puts his hands on his cheeks and
says you're my guy
you're the guy who's gonna be my
sergeant you're my general my leader for
the next 10 years and he's done that
with devin mccourty
and i think in doing that you develop a
certain level of commitment from that
play i mean devon had a
terrible tragedy earlier this summer he
lost a child
in child birth or just before childbirth
he's got multiple kids i mean i'm sure
that
he's got enough money he's got enough
rings he's got enough fame he's
very active in in social justice matters
there's a million things he could do um
but i think that the commitment weighs
on him too
so it'll be interesting to see which way
he goes
if brady was still the quarterback there
do you think these players would be
opting out
i asked the same question yesterday no i
don't
i don't think that would happen i think
that the that they would have a much
harder time
uh explaining look marcus cannon is a
cancer survivor
i think that that is
on its own planet yeah and high tower
and chung
both have newborns um or
soon to have newborns and brandon bolton
had had a
health situation too if i'm not mistaken
but i think when these players look at
it they're like i've made over 30
million dollars i have three rings i'm
over 30 years old
this seems like it's going to be a bit
of a cluster we're going to
sit there in our cars and wait to get
into the facility to have our nose
swabbed
one by one every day then after the nose
swab we have to go through this process
of getting into the locker room then
into the training room then on to the
practice field
for a season that might not happen and i
think that a lot of those players like
do i want to do that to go in there and
go seven and nine
with jared stidham or cam newton or
whatever we're trying to do if brady was
there though dan
i don't think seven and nine would be in
the conversation so
no i don't think that there would be
this many players opting out because
they would be
championship caliber
what about belichick's role in all of
this that i know that he gets
maybe too much credit sometimes maybe
sometimes not enough blame
but this situation where you actually
have people
saying is this a plan by bill belichick
to tank this season do you think that
belichick is capable of doing that
yeah that first germinated with an nfl
executive tweeting
or texting back and forth with adam
schefter and as i said
in response that this explains why
there's so much turnover in the head
coaching in the nfl executive ranks
every three years or so
i mean you can't be any more
staggeringly ridiculously dumb than that
i think that bill belichick would think
it's a great idea
to lose the linchpin of his defense and
dante hightower the right tackle
and then their box safety that's great
yeah let's go out and go 2 and 14. just
like damn was talking about
i mean come on come on he did bench
malcolm butler in the super bowl time
because he thought he'd win anyway
honest to god he thought he would
i mean i had someone close to me go it's
not like they're going to go out there
and score
40 points on
with nick foles right i mean they did
not they did not think nick foles was
great
they made me put my coffee cup down at
the beginning because it was here and
they said it was blocking the shot
yeah but halfway through i need to take
a sip well they probably had a problem
that it says dunkin donuts on it so
we're giving
dunkin donuts some love there well it
says duncan because they took the donuts
off but yeah you're right all right
how's that
yeah that's good yeah
by the way what that's a nice hat you
got is that a cap
it's a scally cap yeah some people call
it a news boy i guess these days
yeah yeah well uh these days or maybe
like you know
70 years ago you know what dan
i don't like the direction of the
conversation things are going great
and uh do you know i will add to this
the one thing about not being in
training camp is going to be fascinating
because they have these three different
classifications for the media
there's something called 2m there's
gonna be 10 slots those
individuals will have to be tested every
day
as well to have any indoor access and
even with new england we might not have
direct access and then there's something
called 30a
which is you never will be in the same
room
as a patriots player and for me i will
never
be i might not see a rep of the new
england patriots until their first game
of the season
because i probably won't be able to get
to practice we'll probably get one
person
out of practice for our place which
generates a ridiculous amount i don't
know how i started on that there was a
point that i wanted to make
um but here i am i just i'm not going to
see a lot of reps so i don't have to
shower up every day
got any cam newton updates for me
they expect him to i think that they are
take this dan and i don't have any
updates
would you and the fellas think that the
lack of a pre-season for cam newton
can somehow be construed as an advantage
for bill belichick i would say that it
does
because no one knows what they're going
to do with them no one knows if they're
going to start stim no one knows they're
going to start newton no one knows what
the offense is going to look like
so that's a place where i say the bill
belichick genius
and subterfuge helps it's great to talk
to you it's great to see you
and thank you i i hope you have a great
week and uh
a great life a great month great season
all of those this isn't goodbye
uh for now okay good yeah like i've got
to resume my regular schedule
programming because you kind of took us
off path here and then
i lost half my audience there when you
were telling about not being able to go
to the facility
people are interested in how the nuts
and bolts how the sausage gets made i
defy you
all right that's tom e curran
uh patriots insider for nbc sports